[Musik]
Der Vatikan markiert Centum der römische
Katalysator in Kita's Konservativer der
Sohn eines Verräters und Problems haben Verrückte und
die Gedächtniskrankheit die können nicht sprechen unsere
Skizze Krippe Konsole Iannetta Geist
Homosexuelle Gemeinschaften entwickeln ein Brennen
der Sporn Hauptmann Rodriguez
referenceusa zeigt ein Telugu  Nationalist
Frederick Martel, wie es in Paris ist,
er und Kanalisation, das ist schwer für mich,
interviewt Pascal.
Guten Tag, Frederick Mattel, wie geht es
Ihnen? Ja, genau, wir sehen niemanden, also
wissen Sie, ich möchte Ihnen danken, dass Sie
mit mir sprechen  Ich bin froh, dass
du bei uns bist. Du weißt, dass es
viel zu tun gibt, also werden wir überleben.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es in einem Monat funktionieren wird,
aber wir werden sehen
, dass wir zu dem Thema Angst kommen, über das ich
ja sprechen wollte  Sie behaupten heute, dass
die vatikanischen Prälaten, Bischöfe und
Kardinäle einerseits schwul sind und andererseits
Homosexualität vehement ablehnen, das klingt einfach nach einem
dramatischen Ja-Szenario, nicht wahr, ja und
nein, wenn Sie  Wenn Sie auf die
Tradition zurückkommen Wenn Sie auf die Vergangenheit zurückkommen
, ist es tatsächlich ziemlich kohärent
und viele Leute sagten zu mir, Sie wissen,
dass es absolut unglaublich ist, dass
sie beide schwul sind und tatsächlich ein Film, wenn Sie
Proust lesen, wenn Sie  Lesen Sie weiter Rasheeda
Bamboo und viele andere Schriftsteller und ich
spreche nur über die Franzosen, aber wir können hier auch
zu viel über Mann
oder Viscount und viele andere in der
Vergangenheit diskutieren, aber sie waren keine Prälaten oder
Bischöfe, richtig, nein, aber das ist dasselbe
zystische unlogische System wie Sie  bist sehr
beweglich,
wenn du selbst entweder schwul bist oder was
sie Omo nennen, feine Tiere, okay, das ist
keine Schauspielerei, und wenn du Angst hast, dass
deine Sexualität öffentlich wird
, ist das eine sehr
traditionelle Schauspielerei und um den Vatikan
und endlich die Kirche zu verstehen, die du brauchst  Um zu
verstehen, dass wir im
Vatikan nicht mit Menschen sind, die im Jahr 2020 leben,
leben sie teilweise noch im Jahr 1950 oder
1960, viele von ihnen und ich habe viele von ihnen getroffen, die ich interviewe
, die 1991 94 Jahre
alt sind  Sie sind mit Leuten zusammen, die
in den 1940er oder 50er Jahren 20 Jahre alt waren, also
bedeutet das, dass sie reagieren, dass sie denken, dass sie im
Grunde ihre Meinung
über Homosexualität vor 70 oder 50 Jahren aufgebaut haben, und
lassen Sie uns alles erklären, was
das ist, was ich nicht gegen sie habe
Ich kritisiere sie nicht, ich versuche,
ihre Art und Weise zu verstehen, und es ist
hauptsächlich eine Frage der Zeit. Ja,
wir kommen an diesen Punkt, aber immer
noch liegt eine explosive Kraft in Ihren
Hypothesen, Sie sagen, dass nein, fangen wir an
wie dieser Mann, der an seiner
Homosexualität festhält und nach der
römisch-katholischen Lehre nicht Priester werden kann
und Sie trotzdem sagen, dass 80 Prozent von ihnen sagen, oder Sie
zitieren jemanden, der sagt, dass 80 Prozent
von ihnen schwul sind, jetzt frage ich mich,
wer die Augen vor der Realität verschließt  und
warum so zuallererst habe ich nie gesagt,
wie du es erwähnt hast, ich glaube,
Reza, vor ein paar Sekunden,
ich habe selbst nie gesagt, dass 80 Prozent
der Menschen im Körper kein Risiko eingehen können, aber
du sagst, es scheint die Mehrheit zu sein, ja,
ich meine  Ich mache keine quantitative
Forschung, weil es einfach unmöglich
ist, dass Sie niemanden kennen, selbst wenn Sie
alle Priester im Vatikan interviewen, werden
sie Ihnen nicht die Wahrheit sagen, also was
ich tue, ist ein quantitatives Sorry, was
ich tue  eine qualitative Forschung, eine
andere quantitative, aber wieder
einmal geht es nicht um die Zahlen
und das Ziel ist nicht zu verstehen, ob der
Priester, der Bischof B oder der Kanoniker LC
schwul ist oder nicht, und ich oute mich nicht oder ich versuche
, das System zu verstehen  weil
er viele Konsequenzen hat, besonders bei
sexuellem Missbrauch, und ich werde das
wahrscheinlich später mit Ihnen besprechen. Der Hauptpunkt
ist, dass es ein soziologisches System ist, wenn
Sie in einem kleinen Dorf
in Italien im Jahr 1950 sexueller sind, auch wenn Sie sich nicht
sicher sind, dass Sie es tun.  Du stehst nicht auf Frauen Du
willst nicht wirklich heiraten Du
hast keine Du hast keine Du hast
keine Nattie rennt zum Sex mit Frauen und
auch wenn du wie in einer bürgerlichen
Familie bist in einer großen  Stadt wie in Mailand oder
Paris oder Zürich i  In den 1950er Jahren und Sie
verstehen, dass es ein Problem gibt,
Priester zu werden, ist eine Lösung. Sie haben Leute
in Ihrer Schule oder im Seminar,
die Witze mit Ihnen machen, die Sie vielleicht tun möchten
, um mit einer Art von verschiedenen speziellen Stimmen zu singen,
damit Sie sie annehmen können
etwas weiblichere Kleidung und all das, was dich
in Schwierigkeiten bringt, sogar deine Mutter, junger Mann,
versteht, dass etwas nicht stimmt,
und sie ist so glücklich über diese plötzliche und
glaubwürdige Berufung,
Priester zu werden, und all deine
Probleme werden zu einer Stärke der Schwäche
denn Stärke, also lebst du nur mit
Männern, du kannst mit der Stimme singen, die du willst,
du kannst die Kleidung anziehen, die du willst, und im
Grunde musst du nicht heiraten und
du musst nicht, um so eine vorgetäuschte
Beziehung mit einer Frau zu haben  es geht
nicht darum, dass die Leute lügen
oder auf eine Art völlig illegale
Art und Weise Dinge
tun, das ist nur eine soziologische Äußerung, und
die Kirche wird rekrutiert, gefördert
und in gewissem Maße akzeptiert, dass dies der Fall ist  Hut
- welcher der Priester oh ja
, ich verstehe, was Sie
meinen. Ich meine, die letzte Pflanze, über die wir reden müssen
, aber das ist vor 50 Jahren, wie
ist es heute,
und wenn es so offensichtlich ist, haben Sie gerade gesagt,
ja, die Kirche akzeptiert es irgendwie,
meine ich  Wenn es so offensichtlich ist, warum noch nie
jemand ein solches Buch geschrieben hat wie Sie, ist
dies eine sehr Krankheit, und es
scheint mir sehr seltsam, zu zweit
vor allem auf die erste Frage heute zu
antworten. Ich denke, es ist ziemlich anders,
zuallererst heterosexuelle Menschen  Wir
verstehen sehr schnell, dass besonders
wenn du Seminarist wirst und ich
viele von ihnen interviewe, sie
diese Art von Omo-Rohtak-Atmosphäre
nicht akzeptieren, zweitens sogar die Schwulen,
denn jetzt ist es selbst in
einem kleinen Dorf in Italien in der Schweiz ganz anders für
dich  Sie haben alle Möglichkeiten, Sie sind nicht
sexuell, also wollen die Leute im Grunde
keine Priester werden. Ich meine, das ist eine Tatsache,
und in gewisser Weise ist es eine quantitative Tatsache. 80
tut mir leid, 800 Priester sind im Grunde genommen
tot  Wenn Sie
nur französische Zahlen haben, sind weniger als 60
Priester jetzt geordnet, was bedeutet, dass es in
fünf oder zehn Jahren überhaupt keinen Priester mehr gibt,
niemand will
mehr Priester werden, die Heteros, also
akzeptieren sie keine Erlaubnis, nicht verheiratet zu sein,
und so weiter  Homosexuelle, weil
es andere Möglichkeiten gibt, jetzt
zum zweiten Punkt, warum dieses Buch
nicht geschrieben wurde und ich würde sagen, es wäre nicht
vor zehn Jahren geschrieben worden, es war
immer noch zu schwierig, das zu sagen, aber
zuerst einmal  also würdest du sagen, es hat sich geändert,
weil es mehr rechte für
homosexuelle gibt, zum beispiel
gleichgeschlechtliche ehe und alles, was
dir geholfen hat, dieses buch zu schreiben, ja,
zweitens gibt es unglaublich große
skandale um sexuellen missbrauch in der
kirche, es geht wieder um tausend  von
Priestern in Australien in den USA  in
Irland, aber oder
in Brasilien, in Mexiko, in Chile und
Zone, die
wegen sexuellen Missbrauchs entschuldigt oder verurteilt wurden, so
dass die Priester keine Sexualität haben
, glaubte niemand mehr, dass
es um Tausende von Menschen geht, die
dafür im Gefängnis waren  oder beschuldigen Sie also,
Sie sprechen von ich meine, Sie
sprechen von außen, aber dann
frage ich mich wieder, wie waren die
Reaktionen auf Ihr Buch, ich meine, Sie
haben es vor einem Jahr geschrieben
reagiere und antworte auf dein Buch Ich
habe auch die Schweizer Bischofskonferenz gefragt, sie
würden keine Erklärung abgeben, sie
sagen, dass sie im Moment mit dem Coronavirus beschäftigt
sind, wie alle, aber ich meine,
wie waren die Reaktionen auch aus
dem Vatikan und nicht  von den Leuten, mit denen
Sie gesprochen haben, und warum dieses
Buch bisher noch nicht geschrieben wurde, denn
wenn Sie ein italienischer Journalist sind, befinden Sie
sich immer noch in einem Land, in dem
so etwas schwierig ist, mit Ihrem
Verleger, mit Ihrer Zeitung, wenn ja  Du bist das,
was wir einen Vatikan nennen. Du kennst diese
ganz besonderen Journalisten, die
hauptsächlich für den Vatikan arbeiten. Du verlierst deinen Job,
wenn du eine Buchzeile schreibst, und wenn du
hetero bist, bekommst du den Code
nicht, dann verstehst du das System nicht  Aus diesem Grund wurde
dieses Buch heute und nicht vor
zehn Jahren von einem französischen Journalisten
geschrieben, der kein
Vatikaninstitut ist, aber um Ihre Frage zu beantworten.
Sie kennen die Reaktion. Wir sind sehr gemischt.
Erstens hat im Grunde niemand, kein Kardinal
gesprochen  darüber und sie haben nicht
einmal geklagt oder angegriffen oder irgendeinen Baum gemacht oder
mit dem Buch, also wurde das Buch
überall veröffentlicht, ohne
rechtliche Probleme. Ich habe nicht geantwortet. Glaubst du
, sie haben nur gedacht, das ist nicht
wichtig für uns?  ist alles Bullshit,
tut mir leid, entschuldigen Sie mein Englisch, aber ich meine,
warum haben sie nicht geantwortet, weil ich meine,
was Sie hier schreiben, ist sehr
explizit
von Schutzmaßnahmen und wir wussten sehr gut,
was  wir machten das Buch
wurde von einem sehr großen
Mainstream-Verlag in Deutschland in
Frankreich in Italien in den USA veröffentlicht.  unter den
berühmtesten, ich meine im Stall, bis zur
Hälfte der Geschichte,
nein, aber ich meine, es ist ein ernstes Buch. Bruce
Barry ist auch der Herausgeber eines
Reporters, also wissen sie nicht, dass es
nicht wie Facebook ist, in dem ich
sagte, wissen Sie  Im Grunde ist jeder
aus dem Vatikan, mit dem ich die
ganze Zeit gesprochen habe, und auch der Kardinal, der
mit mir gesprochen hat. Ich habe mehr als 40
bis 43 Kardinäle interviewt. Ich meine, alle haben
mir die Geschichte erzählt, bis zu einem gewissen Grad
kennt jeder die Geschichte und Sie vielleicht  Sie könnten
diese Tatsache oder diese Seite oder das,
was ich über diese Leute sage, diskutieren,
weil es extrem schwierig ist, an Sexualität zu arbeiten,
und besonders an Sexualität
im Vatikan, aber Sie wissen, dass wir
einen Punkt diskutieren können, aber ich bin mir zu 100% sicher, dass
Gesamttheorie und das ist im
Grunde das, was viele sehr berühmte
Wahnvorstellungen und Leute gesagt haben, sogar der
Papst sagte in einer inoffiziellen und offiziellen
Diskussion mit einem Anwalt,
die überall in Lateinamerika veröffentlicht wurde. In
den USA habe ich das Buch gelesen  Das ist in Ordnung, ich
wusste alles, was Papst Franziskus
sagen würde, das wissen Sie im Grunde, zum Beispiel,
ich diskutiere nicht mehr, um ehrlich zu sein,
mit vielen Leuten im Vatikan, das ist
nicht mehr so ein Buch, aber Sie wissen, ich habe
ine Menge davon.  Ich
finde dort keine Freunde und ich sehe immer noch den
Kardinal-Erzbischof, den Priester, der
mich eingeladen hat, mit ihnen im Vatikan zu leben,
also esse ich immer noch mit
ihnen in Rom in einer Art geheimem
Restaurant zu viel
diskutiert und ich war immer noch sehr freundlich
und glücklich mit mir aber das stimmt das die leute das
thema lieber nicht diskutieren
weil das buch im grunde
eines der wichtigsten geheimnisse der
letzten ja gibt ich meine deine behauptungen
basieren auf privaten gesprächen und wie
kannst du dir sicher sein das die leute das wissen  die
mit Ihnen gesprochen haben, haben die Wahrheit gesagt, Sie
wissen, dass das leider
der Job eines Journalisten ist, Sie wissen, wenn
mir jemand erzählt, dass dieser Kardinal
schwul ist, wissen Sie, dass ich das nicht veröffentlichen würde
, wenn ich es täte  Das haben wir getan, nein, du
outest keine Leute, aber ich versuche zu erklären,
wie es funktioniert.
Ich versuche, nicht gegen jemanden zu sein
Medien
wegen eines Baumes oder und und nur, aber nicht
lebender Kardinäle oder Bischöfe, warum, weil
mein Ziel ist, niemanden zu outen,
sondern das System, den Vatikan zu outen,
aber Sie wissen, dass sie
aufgezeichnet sind, sie wussten, wer ich war, ich nie  Lügen Sie
auf meinen Namen, den niemand
kannte. Ich war ein Journalist, ein
Schriftsteller, der ein Buch über den Vatikan schrieb.
Sie wussten nicht, welche Arbeit ich
tat, was nicht mehr ist, und auch als
sie mich baten, offiziell zu sein,
sind sie offiziell  Meine Regeln, die ich von
der ursprünglichen internationalen angewandt habe, kommen wir also
auf den Papst zurück. Sie sagten, der
Papst weiß, dass Sie sich in Ihren
Ermittlungen auch auf die
Doppelmoral der katholischen Kirche beziehen und in
mehreren Predigten wie von 2016 bis 2018
18 Papst Franziskus anprangern  genau das
warst du s  Aying zeigen wir nur ein
kurzes Video von diesen dreißig aufmerksamen oder
wir Davonte erreichen
Gewissheit Davonte Christiani CNRI billig
relativ sov kc % Anoka c perfecti
starr sony starr dela Tapia etwas
sicherer Nevada Bauch Ehrlichkeit cuándo es una
Live Aid Fund Elly hustet eine breite Reichweite
Evita no neon tetras Evita sie hat
einfach Casa de niñas Fausto in tanta
casi una dopey Evita genannt,
also denkst du, Papst Franziskus weiß wirklich,
was du in diesem Buch geschrieben
hast, und er wusste es, bevor du weißt, dass ich kein
Zauberer bin oder jemand, der einer ist  Ich möchte
etwas beschreiben, das auf Hypothesen basiert,
wenn ich erwähne, dass es daran liegt, dass ich
viele enge Berater von Papst Franziskus getroffen habe.
Natürlich werden sie in meinem Buch verdammt noch mal erwähnt,
einige, die es nicht sind, weil
sie geheim bleiben wollten, und
das haben sie gesagt  Sie haben mir erklärt,
wie es funktioniert, und wenn Sie sich die
Sätze auf der regulären Basis ansehen, dass der
Papst das
Wort verwendet, dh im Gegensatz zu seinen Gegnern, sagt er,
dass extrem c  Übrigens gibt
es viele Programme im Vatikan, Sie
haben ein Programm über Sexualität, und
eigentlich ist es eines davon,
aber Sie sind auch heterosexuelle Menschen, Sie
haben auch Sexualität mit Frauen, Sie haben
ein Problem mit Geld, mit dem Sie ein Programm
haben  Macht und Machtmissbrauch und so weiter
und so weiter und auch du hast natürlich
den sexuellen Missbrauch, das ist ganz anders,
dass keine Sexualität mehr ist und du weißt,
wen du kennst, mit dir auch zu sprechen,
weil ich weiß, dass du dich für
Religion interessierst und ich denke  Ihre Zuhörer auch,
Sie müssen mir nicht glauben, Sie müssen
das Buch nicht einmal lesen,
vertrauen Sie mir, aber wenn Sie das
System nächsten Monat und den Monat danach
und das Jahr danach nicht verstehen, werden
Sie immer wieder ja verzweifeln
Skandale und Enthüllungen und das
Outing und neu, es wird eine unendliche
Geschichte. Lassen Sie mich eine weitere Frage stellen,
weil ich mehr darüber wissen möchte, dass
Sie Homosexualität als den Hauptschlüssel zum
Verständnis des Vatikans bezeichnen, und könnten Sie
das noch erklären?  re ich meine du hast
damit angefangen aber in welchem sinn gibt es da
einen zusammenhang zwischen homosexualität und d
hast sogar dieses vatileaks thema bei d
n finanzen gesagt in welcher weise ist homos
xualität in ja es steht in einem zusammenhang damit
mein fokus ist homos
xualität und ich bin  Ziemlich weit gefasst, wenn
man sich das Thema ansieht, weil ich auch über
Geld diskutiere Die Verbindung mit der extremen
Rechten Die Funktion des Vatikans in
vielen anderen Aspekten, aber ja, ich denke, meine
Sexualität ist einer der Schlüssel zur
Erklärung, nicht noch einmal, ich habe kein
Problem damit  ein Bischof oder Kardinal ist
schwul Ich meine, wenn sie einen Liebhaber haben, wenn
sie Sex haben, ist mir egal, ich meine, für mich
sollte es erlaubt sein, das einzige Problem ist, wenn
es um Minderjährige geht, wenn es um
Prostitution geht oder wenn es um Missbrauch geht, und das
ohne Zustimmung  Es und auch
im Vatikan gibt es eine Besonderheit
dieser Art der Wasserkrise, wie wir
auf Französisch sagen, die ein zwielichtiger Senior ist, wenn
jemand, weil ja Macht ein Bischof ist
oder nicht gezeigt wird, eine Seminaria um sexuelle Gunst bitten kann
n oder Priester, der
keine Macht hat, also bedeutet das, dass die einzigen
Dinge die anderen betreffen, die mir nichts ausmachen
und mir egal sind, und ich bin ehrlich, ich
bevorzuge einen Priester oder Bischof mit einem
Freund als einen Priester, der ein Kind berührt  von
zehn jahren das wars ja aber meine
frage war in welchem sinn sind diese theme
miteinander verwoben also sagst du auch dass
omosexualität in gewissem sinne
ein schlüsselfaktor ist wenn es darum geht bekan
ter skandale der katholischen kirche zu teilen was a
ch ein set ist  das aber ist dann der
sex-missbrauchsskandal in deinen augen auch ein
torskandal oder in welchem sinne muss
an das verstehen und auch diffe
enzieren, damit nicht homos
xualität und pädophilie richtig gemischt werden denn
as wäre ja die gefah
ja ich meine dich  Sie sehr, Ihre
Frage ist sehr gut, und Sie haben
sehr recht,
das Problem ist das Problem
der Geheimhaltungskultur, wenn Sie ein
System und eine Organisation haben, die auf Lügen basieren,
und eigentlich könnten Sie
mir nicht zustimmen  und du könntest  Es gefällt mir nicht, das zu
sagen, aber ich denke darüber nach und ist
hauptsächlich eine Lügenorganisation. Alles
dreht sich um Lügen. Sie lügen über Geld. Sie lügen
über die Organisation. Sie lügen über die
Macht und Sie lügen über Sexualität
eine Kultur der Geheimhaltung und der Lüge haben, die
so groß ist, dass es Menschen geben kann, deren
Sexualität völlig verboten ist, wie
sexueller Missbrauch, die auch durch
diese Kultur der Lüge geschützt werden, und ich denke, das ist
das Problem, das Problem ist nicht die
Sexualität, die Homosexualität, unter der
wir das kennen  Viele Studien haben keinen Zusammenhang
mit sexuellem Missbrauch. Sexueller Missbrauch in
der Welt im Allgemeinen findet hauptsächlich in der
Familie oder in Schulen statt und die Opfer sind
hauptsächlich Mädchen und daher heterosexuell.
Ja, und es ist hauptsächlich ein sexueller Terror
überall auf der Welt, aber in der
Kirche, wir auch  wissen, dass die Opfer von
Priestern je nach Studie zwischen 80 und 85 Prozent
Männer oder Jungen sind, also
gibt es eine Besonderheit in der katholischen
Kirche, die eine Verbindung zwischen ihnen herstellt  Diese
Anziehungskraft für Jungen und sexueller Missbrauch, warum
ist das nicht alles, was das meiste Sexualitätsprogramm
ist?  In der Strategie des
Ideals und nicht einmal zu akzeptieren,
was du bist, deshalb gehst du, wenn du
Sex haben willst, zu Kindern,
zu Migranten und zu Priestern von
Seminaristen, weil du ihnen gegenüber eine
Autorität hast und sie nicht  Um
es so einfach zu sagen, dass Sie versuchen
, Sex mit Leuten zu haben, die nicht
sprechen werden. Natürlich gehen Sie nicht in
eine Schwulenbar und sagen: „Hey, ich bin ein Kardinal
oder ich bin ein Bischof und ich bin es  interessiert von
Ihnen, Sie müssen eine Strategie der
Vertuschung haben, und das ist der Grund, warum das
System als Zusammenstoß ein System ist,
das sexuellen Missbrauch schützt, obwohl und ich
bestehe darauf, obwohl das Ziel
des Papstes oder des Bischofs des Kontinents
ist  natürlich nicht um den sexuellen Missbrauch zu schützen
Unter der Prämisse, dass Sie sie schützen,
weil Sie die allgemeine Lüge nicht diskutieren können,
würde sich das Problem
in einigen Jahrzehnten von selbst lösen, wenn die Gesellschaft
immer mehr für das Recht von
Homosexuellen ist, nicht wahr, und das sind auch
die großen Probleme, die Sie kennen  Vor
den 70er Jahren, wissen Sie, 1960 sind die
70er Jahre, die Kirche, die Sie kennen, war grundsätzlich
gegen Schwule, aber die Gesellschaft
insgesamt war auch Homosexualität
verboten, manchmal kriminalisiert, und so war
die Kirche im Grunde überhaupt nicht einzigartig.
Das Problem ist, wenn die Gesellschaft
wurde vor allem
in den 90er Jahren viel schwulenfreundlicher, aber selbst ab den 80er Jahren muss
die Kirche noch amorpher
sein, entweder das Geheimnis, es ist immer ein
sehr komplexes System, in dem Sie
fast Sexualität haben, alle fast
sexuell, Sie haben jemals Geld gesehen  das spielt
in den usa vor allem marcial maciel kadima oder goya oder mckarrick eine ganz zentrale rolle
Im Idealfall waren viele von ihnen
extrem rechts,
also Priester, die
dem Vatikan viel Geld gaben, aber auch
gegen die Befreiung
des Kommunismus in Lateinamerika durch Terrorschiffe kämpften und
deshalb von
Johannes Paul dem Zweiten beschützt wurden  und sogar von papst
benedikt xvi. es tut mir leid, sie dabei zu
unterbrechen, aber ich frage mich, ob sie mit
diesem buch, so wie es geschrieben ist, auch
mit einigen schadenfrohen details und
allem, wirklich die wahren gläubigen erreichen,
die zu erreichen wichtig wären
tatsächlich und Sie selbst sind
kein Gläubiger, den Sie in Ihr Buch schreiben, und
Sie glauben mehr an Literatur als an
Religion, die Sie schreiben, also glauben Sie wirklich,
dass Sie sie erreichen können, oder war das
überhaupt eine Ihrer Ideen, sie zu erreichen, Sie
wissen, ich bekomme jeden Tag 10  Briefe von hauptsächlich
von Priestern von Katholiken von ehemaligen Priestern
ehemaligen Katholiken, die mir ihr
Leben erzählen und sie entdecken im Grunde
das System in meinem Buch und
sie sind schockiert, weil sie sagen, oh das
w  Als mein Eindruck, oh das war der Grund,
warum ich aufgehört habe, Priester zu sein, oh, ich
wurde von diesen Priestern missbraucht und so weiter
und so fort, und ich möchte keine
eigene Werbung machen, aber das Buch war die
Nummer eins der Bestseller  Frankreich ja, es
war ein Bestseller mehr als 15 Länder
wir verkauften wahrscheinlich mehr als 600 ein bisschen
weniger ein bisschen mehr wir wissen nicht genau
tausendsechshunderttausend Exemplare
auf der ganzen Welt, also war die
Reaktion der Leute selbst das, was wir nennen
Auf Französisch sagen wir, Baskisch ist jetzt ein Anliegen,
es bedeutet, weil es sie betrifft,
weil es um ihr Leben geht, und
Sie wissen also gleichzeitig, wenn Sie ein
Schriftsteller sind, bin ich ein Schriftsteller, bin ich ein Journalist,
ich bin es auch nicht  Katholisch und auch offen
schwul, also darunter, aber Sie sind ein ehemaliger
Katholik, richtig, tut mir leid, ja, ich war
bis zum Alter von 10 Jahren katholisch, ja, wie jeder in
Frankreich, aber ich bin ein kultureller Katholik, ich
meine, ich bin in einem System aufgewachsen wie
jeder in  dieses Land und ich bin
stolz darauf
Ich bin sehr stolz auf Sie wissen, dass ich Rambo mag
und ich mag Berlin, ich mag bescheiden und ich
sehe nicht einmal, dass sie auch
katholisch waren und eine Nicht-Null machen, aber
natürlich bin ich eine rein säkulare Person in
Frankreich und und LGBT-freundlich und offen
schwul, wie ich sagte, aber ich '  Ich bin ein Forscher Ich
mache Dinge, die meiner Meinung nach Misserfolge sind,
und ja, aber mein Ziel ist das Ziel des
Schriftstellers Ich bin kein Richter Ich verurteile sie nicht
Ich will nicht - ich will die Kirche nicht ändern,
weil  Das ist nicht meine Aufgabe, meine
Aufgabe ist es, ein System zu erklären und zu beschreiben
, und dann können die Leute handeln, wenn
sie wollen, aber das ist nicht, ich habe keine
politische Agenda, ja, aber trotzdem wurde
Ihnen vorgeworfen, Ihre Forschung
mit Ihrem persönlichen Aktivismus zu verwechseln
Homosexuellenrechte, das war ein Punkt, von dem die Leute
dachten, dass er ein Problem sein könnte,
ja, aber das ist falsch. Ich meine, Sie können
das von Jungfräulichkeit sagen, und Sie können
diesen Organismus nicht einstellen, Sie wissen, wenn Sie mich kennen
und wenn Sie gelesen haben, was ich geschrieben habe, war
ich gut  Ich bin seit langem einer der
Kunstkritiker. Ich kritisiere die schwule Community
sehr, besonders in Th  Über die AIDS-Epidemie habe
ich mehrere Bücher geschrieben, in denen auch
mein eigenes Volk kritisiert wird,
also wissen Sie, dass ich von Katholiken erwarte, dass sie
dasselbe tun, um auch ihr eigenes Volk zu kritisieren
Ich meine gegen
Katholiken oder gegen Priester, ja
das ist es und natürlich weißt du, wenn
du ein Buch wie dieses schreibst, weißt du
am Anfang drei Dinge, erstens, dass du
angegriffen wirst,
zweitens, du kannst nicht alles sagen, was
du weißt, und drittens  vor allem kannst du nicht
einmal alles verstehen, was so
verrückt ist
diese welt ist so erstaunlich diese welt ist
so vollgestopft mit gefälschten nachrichten und
lügen und unwahrheiten, dass es
sehr schwierig ist, viele aspekte des buchs zu verstehen,
deshalb habe ich zum beispiel
nie darüber gesprochen  Taubes Beispiel das
erste oder die Ermordung der Schweizergarde
im Vatikan, denn am
Ende weiß ich nicht, dass Bücher und Artikel
darüber geschrieben wurden, aber ich möchte nicht
weiter darauf eingehen  s Thema, weil ich nicht die Wahrheit frage,
wenn ich etwas schreibe,
weil ich mir 100% sicher bin und das Buch
nicht auf Gerüchten oder Anspielungen
basiert, es basiert nur auf Tatsachen der Polizei,
danke Frederic für diese Klarstellung und
auch über Töne und  Ich erstelle auf der
Website ein mehr als 300
Seiten umfassendes Dokument über Quellen
leider Zeugenaussagen und so weiter Leute
können das nachschauen leider ist unser
Gespräch schon vorbei ich danke dir vielmals für
die Aufklärung zu unserem Skypegespräch und
alles Gute dir danke a  viel
[Musik]
du